well we've only just received the report
ourselves so we need to study it
carefully obviously we know all of the
evidence that's been heard at the
inquiry over the last few years
what I would say is that with the
benefit of hindsight there should have
been more work in relation to reviewing
the information that was being gathered
and more care taken in relation to the
groups that were being infiltrated
can you guarantee people that this kind
of thing isn't still going on
what I can say is that undercover
policing is a very legitimate tactic and
that it saves lives and protects people
from crime
what was going on 40 years ago Bears no
resemblance at all to how undercover
policing is now in 2023 I appreciate
that people are going to want to know
what's going on right now and of course
it wouldn't be appropriate for me to
confirm or deny exactly what is
happening right now because it would
compromise it well do police officers
still use deceased babies names
absolutely not do police officers sleep
with women who do not know that they're
police officers absolutely not I have to
see I must say that it is absolutely
abhorrent the activities of those
officers in the sexual relationships
that they had
it I apologize we have already
apologized it should never have taken
place and and managers should have known
what was going on and stopped it and do
police officers infiltrate groups become
members of groups that are not a threat
to public protection in order to perhaps
stop demonstrations
what I can say now is that in 2023 the
legislation and the governance over how
undercover policing is run is completely
different to how it was 40 to 50 years
ago and there were far more checks and
balances on what officers are deployed
to do but of course I'm not going to be
commenting on live or current undercover
policing for obvious reasons